welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka death Vader and
those season one of the Mandalorian tied
up pretty well it's still left one big
question in the air that is who did the
boots belong to at the end of Episode
five it's something that we still don't
have concrete answers on and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the best fan theories and giving
all of the evidence to support them
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch the
series yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of the Mandalorian
okay so episode 5 of the mandalorian
centers around the titular character
traveling to Tatooine after being hunted
throughout the galaxy by a wealth of
bounty hunters that all want to get
their hands on baby otter mono ship was
heavily damaged and in order to fix it
he needed to find work after teaming up
with an ambitious mercenary named Toro
the two went on the hunt for a fugitive
named vanish and though they captured
her after realizing that his partner had
one of the biggest bounties on his head
in the galaxy Toro double-crossed mando
and decided to kill SH and mando managed
to save the day and baby Yoda thank God
but the episode ended on a lingering
shot of a mysterious character walking
up to Shands body to investigate it it's
something that as of yet we haven't had
answers to in the show and even in the
light of confirmation from the series
producers there still exists a lot of
speculation around it so who do the crew
say that it is well they have stated
that this is actually the first
appearance of Mothe Gideon this seems
like the most likely option and it makes
sense that the character that turned out
to be the big bad would be teased
earlier in the season before his final
appearance the Mothe not only wears a
cape but he also has imperial wear which
this shot definitely seems to line up
with from fennecs dress we can assume
that she did have ties with the Empire
the dark black armor is a key
characteristic of many high-ranking
members of the Imperial forces and
Gideon himself rolls with death troopers
that all wear a similiar attire it is
possible a fennec was part of his unit
and after she went rogue she fled to
Tatooine the moth would have enough
money to put a bounty on her head and it
is likely that you would be tracking it
too so yeah it does make sense that he
would finally catch up to her after she
was killed
neither Toro or mando took her in so the
character travelling to her last known
location does fit in with his MO
especially because we know he likes to
tackle problems head-on so it does all
seem pretty clear-cut the crew confirm
it the character going after her makes a
lot of sense and he's dressed very
similar however there's still a large
part of the internet community that
believes it is someone
a Star Wars jaian that will be making
their long-awaited return in the second
season of the show what if it isn't them
off and we've already seen the Skywalker
saga character and he has a lot of ties
with the Mandalorian well one of the big
theories going around is that the boots
actually belonged to Boba Fett
this is getting a lot of publicity due
to the fact that the Spurs sounds are
very very similar to the ones that we
heard during a pivotal scene in The
Empire Strikes Back I'm going to play
the clips twice so you can decide for
yourself but you can definitely hear why
people believe that this could be the
galaxy's most famous bounty hunter
[Music]
so they do sound very very similar and
we know for definite that the second
season of the mandalorian will bring
back a major major character from the
Skywalker saga
this has been widely publicized in
mainstream media and now it could be
wishful thinking it is what fans seem to
want I mean who doesn't want to see man
now going head-to-head with Boba Fett I
certainly do and the show itself does
sort of have reimagining zuv characters
whether it's baby oder IG 11 or the main
protagonist when the Mandalorian was
announced a lot of fans including myself
wondered why Disney didn't just do ab of
a fete show especially because of the
characters quote unquote bad death in
the main cannon I am glad we got the
show that we did but it would be awesome
to see the old mix within you and I
definitely wouldn't be disappointed if
they decided to go that route but how
did the character survive I mean we all
seen him go into the Sarlacc on his way
to an agonizing death that would see him
being digested for a thousand years
right well in the expanded universe the
character actually managed to escape the
pit after the events of Return of the
Jedi his apparent death on Tatooine ties
in with the location of the episode and
this appearance at the end would sort of
be a joining of the show into the movie
franchise as this episode also provided
due to the planet that it takes place on
I'd love to see who the toughest bounty
hunter in the galaxy is and watch mando
and fat go head-to-head
another theory that's floating around
online is that the character is actually
Cobb banth a sheriff on Tatooine Cobb
protects an area on the planet known as
free town and in the expanded universe
the character makes his first appearance
between the events of Return of the Jedi
and the force awakens which is also when
the Mandalorian is set now what makes it
possible is that it could be this
seemingly random character is that
before becoming a sheriff Vande managed
to acquire Mandalorian armor from a
group of jurors that may or may not have
taken it from Bob Baffert's corpse with
his best car steal of vanta was able to
become a lawman
and an authority of Freetown and due to
its location on Tatooine it could be
possible that here's the character that
we see approaching Shan at the end of
the fifth episode the timeline matches
up the area does too and the spur sounds
being a match make a lot of sense
whether there is one more character that
I think it is that not only ties into
Fett but also the merchandise of the
show before we get into that though I
just wanna let you know we're giving
away a free copy of Joker to one random
subscriber well you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning it's like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on who you think the boots
belong to in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen tomorrow on
the 15th of January and the cell be
shipped out from then - ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part okay anyway so if you've
been keeping a close eye out on the
Funko pop releases for the show you may
have noticed that in the second wave
there was a character that didn't really
appear in the series this mysterious
female is wearing Mandalorian armor and
also has a couple of notable features
that make it seem likely that this could
be the person who the boots belong to
not only does this character possessed
similar footwear but they also have a
cape that is very akin to the one that
we see at the end of episode 5 if she is
a bounty under then it makes sense why
she would be hot on the heels of Baek
Shan the high value target in the entry
a doubt Disney are commissioning fungo
pops like this when we haven't seen the
character on-screen and this person's
clearly been put into a very limited
lineup of releases for a specific reason
but why would her walk sound like Boba
Fett's well if it does turn out to be
this character then the Spurs themselves
could be a little hint that this is a
Linnell the daughter of Boba Fett in the
expanded Legend series aelin was born
approximately 15 BBY when bobba fett
himself was just about 18 years old
she's a mix of two great bounty hunters
and her mother herself Cintas Belle was
also a well known mercenary throughout
the galaxy
boba walked out on her and her mother
and she grew to hate him
Cintas trained her and she became adept
at firearms and hand-to-hand combat
unfortunately when Aylan was 15 her
mother was killed during the pursuit of
a bounty in which he'd attempted to get
credits to buy alien a birth
present alien was naturally devastated
and due to her father's absence the
character gained a vendetta against him
and sat on a mission to kill baba
blaming him for a mother's death alien
became a very successful bounty hunter
and dedicated many many years to hunting
him down she even managed to kill a
clone of Jango Fett that she believed
was Bubba and that point she masqueraded
his fare during several missions
unfortunately well never got the chance
to kill her father as she was murdered
by Jason solo Han and Leia's child who
became a Sith Lord in the expanded
universe however now that all of that
has been wiped it is possible for Disney
to go in a new direction and bring the
character back the cape and boots seem
similar to you and with this character
being added to the lineup of merchandise
I definitely think that it's possible
that this could be revealed to be the
owner of the mysterious boots these
boots are made for walking and that's
just what they'll do one of these days
these boots are gonna show up in season
two sorry I was that was absolutely
atrocious dear me now obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the theories
and who you think the boots belong to
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of how Mobius connects to
the MCU we go over all of the ins and
outs of how the universes are going to
tie together in front of the camera and
behind the scenes so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more you can support the show by
subscribing to us on patreon and if you
want to come chat to us after the video
you can join our discord server in the
description below or follow us on
twitter at definition YT that's the best
way to keep up to date with everything
we do at heavy spoilers and hopefully we
see over there very soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you